I noticed you were low on canned corn
when Hades gave you the Ember Mao he
made it clear that you have a hard time
using it to its full capacity he even
said that the Ember only works for him
but you were confident that it would
work for you too after all you are his
daughter
but as Hades pointed out you're only
half Hades so the Ember would be way
less powerful in your hands than in
Hades so tell us now why did you think
you could control it and why did you
need Yuma's help to wield it Hades made
it clear to mouth that if the Ember got
wet it would be game over but she
managed to revive it when we finally
know how keep watching to the end to
discover why uma secret family history
make all the difference
after Hades gives mal his Ember he warns
her and it does get wet almost right
away when Ulla gets ahold of it mal
freaks out begging uma to give it back
before it goes out but it doesn't go out
or lose its power
so the question on everyone's mind was
why not it's because uma has hold of the
Ember when it first goes underwater
she's in her half human half octopus
form which means she's controlling the
water and can protect the Ember from it
so we get a clue really early on that
uma is going to be the key to the Ember
working properly for mal and mouths
Blood linked to Hades start showing
straight away - as soon as she steps
through the barrier to leave the Isle of
the Lost her hair gets blue streaks and
it stays blue even when she doesn't have
a hold of the Ember uma stores it in her
mother's necklace and that part is key
to why the ember is revived keep
watching to discover Ursula's roll
well angelfish the solution to your
problem is simple now an uma s--
friendship continues to mend when
they're in the fairy's cottage in the
woods they remember mouth shrimpy
insults - uma and think about how they
could have still been close if it hadn't
been for that it's just as well they
have that moment as they need to work
together with Audrey boards up the
cottage Mau tries to chant a spell on
her own but her magic isn't strong
enough
Lumis shell necklace which is encasing
the Ember starts glowing and that
prompts Puma to join hands with now
together they chant and the wooden
boards do disappear Evy points out that
they did it together
uma acknowledges the bond saying to
mount I guess Michelle likes you and she
then takes out the Ember and returns it
to mal however it's out of mouse
possession again not too long after that
and it's revealed that mal lied to them
about closing the barrier for good Celia
is so angry she throws the Ember into a
well and it does actually go out
Hades warning was right now desperately
tries to use her own magic to revive it
and it doesn't work now looks to Allah
for help but luma just looks at her
necklace and walks away
cut to Audrey on the roof holding Celia
prisoner now turns into her dragon self
and tries breathing fire on the Ember to
reignite it
and that doesn't work and Audrey fires
the magic of maleficents scepter at her
Houma points out that mal doesn't stand
a chance without the Ember so she calls
up to mal were stronger together I'm
right here
shining the light of Ursula's shell
necklace uma chants and it worked which
leaves us with the question why does the
combined power of mal in Tina making
amber revive it's all down to their
family history
mal is a demigod and uma is also a
demigod so if you put the two halves
together you get full God's power wait
let's back up
uma is a demigod you bet and that's
because her mother Ursula's family
background did you know that Ursula and
King Triton are siblings there's an
alternative opening of The Little
Mermaid with a longer version of the
fathoms below song the sailors
explicitly sing about Ursula Bean King
Triton sister but because that bit was
cut it was never explicit to the
audience so Ursula is the daughter of
Poseidon the god of the sea that's made
explicit in the Broadway musical as is
the detail that Poseidon gave her the
magical nautilus shell that's why Ursula
shell necklace is so powerful for uma
and the ember' add in the power
friendship yeah we really got a torn-up
that all together and it's no wonder the
ever revived we post new and exciting
descendants theories every single week
so make sure to subscribe to the things
if you haven't already and don't forget
to turn on those post notifications to
be the first to watch our newest videos
if you're watching the things on your
mobile you can turn on notifications in
the YouTube settings so that's a wrap on
why Hades ember is revived in d3 which
descendants friendship do you love the
most
let us know in the comments hades ember
was revived in descendants three for
this intriguing reason give this video a
big thumbs up if you love descendants
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time on the things
you